well if maybe you just got home from
work or you just returned from running
some errands and let's say maybe you've
got your car parked outside
you need to listen to this next report
you could be the victim of a vehicle
theft now we're not just talking about
your actual
car being stolen but items inside being
stolen
and that could lead to other crimes
madison kimbrough joining us now live
tonight here at six o'clock because
there are some items that we often just
leave in our car
that you need to take out right now
madison that is very very true so if you
park your car in a public lot or on the
side of the street there are some items
you
definitely need to take with you one
being a garage remote
another one being a car charger and your
registration a metro is sending out this
warning after seeing several social
media posts
regarding car thefts and burglaries
i don't know where this guy comes to my
car
while i'm inside the car my car is
tinted so he's come
he comes to my car pulls out a gun
shoots my back window out my car was
parked actually
in the parking lot where i live they
came along in the middle of the night
and decided to take the catalytic
converter
you probably see it daily on apps like
ring and next door
a suspicious person looking for unlocked
cars or
tools stolen out of a truck whether
you're at home at the mall
store or work you need to take lock and
hide
usually my experience is they're checked
they check the car doors to see if
they're unlocked and then they rifle the
car
rifle for change or things of that
nature if you leave something and they
have a flashlight
and it looks an opportunity for them
they
they will break the windows items such
as your purse laptop or any valuable
equipment
even items like car chargers and your
garage opener can tempt a thief
blankets and clothes are another no-no
because even if the thief doesn't want
those belongings
they may think you have something
underneath them security expert tommy
byrne says
even if you follow all those steps it
may still happen
and reporting the issue is key if you
give video give it to the police
put it on your app whichever one you're
on post a picture of somebody
if they're roaming the neighborhood as
for victims like nelson he says this
recent incident of his
really opened his eyes a scary moment
and it it woke me up because i never
thought it would happen to me
now i mentioned hiding that phone
charger but you're also going to want to
hide
the phone cord it's not so much that
they would want this but they may think
that an ipad
or a phone is in the car with it as well
so coming up at 6
30 we will go over what you need to do
to stay safe
to take lock and hide reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now
it's really important the phone cord and
these days kids also have electronics
items
they leave in the car so important that
they are hidden too get them out of
there right denise
yeah brian i was surprised by the
registration because you normally just
keep that in your glove box right with
your insurance but let's say you're
going shopping and you're going to
multiple stores
you have to make sure that you hide all
those bags too don't just leave them on
the front seat
put them in the trunk if you have an suv
a lot of them have that you know that
cover for the back go ahead and use it
invest in one for sure just everything
you can do for the deterrent